nicole kidman and keith urban's
daughters make a rare appearance at the
2021 golden globe awards
i mean my kids are always like what is
she doing now
our crazy mama the undoing actress
celebrated her nomination
at home sunday night joined by her
husband keith urban
and their two daughters 12 year old
sunday and 10 year old faith
the famous fam got a laugh out of this
joke in hosts tina fey
and amy poehler's opening monologue the
undoing
was a sexy and dramatic mystery where
nicole kidman's coat
is suspected of murdering her wig
nicole was up for best actress in a
limited series anthology series or
motion picture made for television
although she didn't win she and her fam
gladly applauded anya taylor joy
who took home the trophy any mother will
tell you
there's just no matter what happens no
matter where you go what happens how it
happens
there's always love waiting for you here
the urbans weren't the only family
celebrating the golden globes together
aaron sorkin was joined by his loved
ones viola davis had her hubby and
daughter by her side
and kate hudson was joined by her squad
including her mama
goldie hawn andre day's nearest and
dearest were there when she won the
award for best actress in a motion
picture drama
jason bateman got some support from his
kids
so did mark ruffalo his kids couldn't
hold back their excitement when their
dad won
best actor in a limited series anthology
series or
tv movies
meanwhile kaylee cuoco celebrated with
her husband sister and glam squad
and naturally ended the night on the
ground eating sweets
gown tiara and all
you